-President Trump has been
floating the possibility
of using military force
in Venezuela.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
You might recall that during
the presidential campaign,
Trump tried to pretend
that he was anti-war.
Despite supporting the Iraq war
at the time,
he claimed repeatedly
that he was against it
and even confronted Jeb Bush
to his face
about his brother's decision
to invade Iraq.
-Obviously, the war in Iraq was
a big fat mistake, all right?
The war in Iraq, we spent
$2 trillion, thousands of lives.
We don't even have it.
Iran is taking over Iraq
with the second-largest
oil reserves in the world.
Obviously, it was a mistake.
George Bush made a mistake.
We can make mistakes.
But that one was a beauty.
We should have never
been in Iraq.
We have destabilized
the Middle East.
-"And if I'm president,
I won't stop at the Middle East.
I'll destabilize
the entire world."
[ Laughter ]
Also, I don't know
why you're yelling at Jeb
about the Iraq war.
You think they checked with him?
[ Laughter ]
They barely let him
in the family photos.
[ Laughter ]
Look how red Trump's face is.
How is it possible
for a human being
to blend into their background
like that?
I knew he changed positions
all the time.
But I didn't think
he was an actual chameleon.
Comments like that led some
pundits to the absurd conclusion
that Trump was somehow anti-war,
like this now infamous headline
from the "New York Times"
op-ed page --
"Donald the Dove,
Hillary the Hawk."
Donald Trump is many things,
but he is not a dove.
New Yorkers hate him,
and he eats fast food.
He's clearly a pigeon.
[ Laughter ]
He even --
[ Applause ]
For what it's worth...
he even stands like a pigeon.
[ Laughter ]
And we knew --
we knew Trump was lying
about his supposed
anti-war leanings
because he kept repeating one of
his favorite talking points --
"When we invaded Iraq, we should
have taken the country's oil."
He even foreshadowed
a possible return to Iraq
in a speech at CIA headquarters
the day after his inauguration.
-The old expression -- "To
the victor belong the spoils."
You remember I always used to
say, "Keep the oil."
I wasn't a fan of Iraq.
I didn't want to go into Iraq.
But I will tell you, when
we were in, we got out wrong.
And I always said, in addition
to that, "Keep the oil."
Now, I said it
for economic reasons.
But if you think about it, Mike,
if we kept the oil,
you probably wouldn't have ISIS,
'cause that's where they made
their money in the first place.
So we should have kept the oil,
but okay.
Maybe you'll have
another chance.
-Wait, what?
What do you mean,
another chance?
You can't just tease something
like that and then move on.
That's like dropping news
on your parents
while you're hanging up
on the phone.
"Okay, Mom, I've got to run.
I love you, too.
Deb and I are splitting up.
Bye."
One of these days
we're going to find out
that Trump sold the country
to Russia
in the middle
of one of his rambles.
"We're having
the Clemson team over.
We're serving them Big Macs.
They have that sauce.
It's like Russian dressing,
which, you know,
it's from Russia,
which is fitting because
they own the White House now."
And Iraq is not the only country
Trump has teased as a target
for regime change.
According to
Bob Woodward's book "Fear,"
Trump once told former
Defense Secretary James Mattis
he wanted to take out
Syrian dictator Bashar al-Assad,
but Mattis ignored him.
Trump called Mattis
and said he wanted
to assassinate the dictator.
"Let's [bleep] kill him.
Let's go in.
Let's kill the [bleep] lot
of them," Trump said.
Mattis told the President
that he would get right on it,
but after hanging up the phone,
he told a senior aide,
"We're not gonna
do any of that."
It is amazing that
you can just ignore
the President
of the United States,
and he'll probably forget
what he asked you to do.
He's like a dog who really wants
a tennis ball.
If you just fake throw it
and then put it in a drawer,
he'll forget about it.
So, Trump the dove asked
the Secretary of Defense
to kill a Syrian dictator
and teased a potential return to
Iraq to take the country's oil.
And now he's threatening
the possibility
of military action in Venezuela.
-We have now heard that
the Trump administration
has unveiled sanctions
on Venezuela's oil industry,
and they've actually implied
we could soon see
military action there.
-Republican senator
Lindsey Graham confirmed
that President Trump has mused
about possible military
intervention in Venezuela.
-Is there any circumstance
under which American forces
would get involved?
-Look, the President has made it
very clear on this matter
that all options
are on the table.
-Are you considering
a military option for Venezuela?
-We're not considering anything,
but all options
are on the table.
-Does that mean
you're considering...
-Just all options always.
All options are on the table.
-All options are on the table.
That's reminding me
of something.
Oh, right.
There it is.
[ Laughter ]
"Help yourself, guys.
All options are on the table.
We have all
the McNugget sauces."
When Trump says all options
are on the table,
it's because he doesn't know
what the options are.
He knows military,
and that's it.
Someone should dare him
to name a second option.
"Well, there's military,
then there's Army,
and then if we have to,
we'll send in the space force."
[ Laughter ]
Now, there's no question that
there's a serious humanitarian
and political crisis
in Venezuela,
and the regime
of President Nicolás Maduro,
who won a rigged election
in May, is genuinely awful.
This is Maduro.
You probably recognize him
from the classic dictator look
sported by guys
like Joseph Stalin,
Saddam Hussein,
and the Soup Nazi.
[ Laughter ]
Maduro has presided
over an economic catastrophe
in Venezuela.
Just to give you an idea,
Venezuela used to be
one of the world's richest
oil-producing countries.
Now there are widespread food
shortages and hyperinflation
that has rendered the currency
essentially worthless.
-The economic free fall
is from falling oil prices
and failed economic policies.
The government
printed more money,
and bills became so worthless,
women turned them into art.
Inflation could hit 10,000,000%.
That's how many bolívars
it costs to buy a chicken.
It takes a stack
of almost-worthless paper
to buy toilet paper.
-Look at that.
That's how much money it takes
to buy toilet paper.
You might as well use the money
instead of the toilet paper.
"Honey, that Chipotle
isn't sitting well with me.
Can you pass me $1 million?"
Maduro has jailed prisoners,
cracked down on dissidents
to try to stay in power.
Meanwhile, many Western nations
have recognized
opposition leader Juan Guaidó
as the legitimate president,
which means there are
two rival presidents.
The political situation
is so crazy,
there's even
a rival supreme court.
And it isn't even in Venezuela.
For the last year and a half, a
second Venezuelan supreme court
has presided over
the country's laws
through the miracle
of cloud computing.
Its 33 jurists live in the U.S.,
Panama, Colombia, and Chile.
Every 15 days, they hold court
via video conference
in what Bloomberg called
"a Skype judiciary."
They're making supreme court
decisions via Skype.
I can't even figure out
how to Skype with my mom.
Everything's on
a five-second delay,
and every other word cuts out.
That must be why
all their cases are called
"say that again" v.
"just send me a text."
There's no question
that Venezuela is in crisis.
The question is, what's the best
way to resolve the crisis
without making things worse?
On the one hand, countries
like Mexico and Uruguay
have already proposed
a new process
of inclusive
and credible negotiations
to seek a peaceful resolution
to the conflict.
On the other hand,
the Trump administration
has chosen to back Guaidó
and impose sanctions.
Vice President Mike Pence
even secretly called Guaidó
and told him the U.S.
would support his claim
to the presidency
and recorded a message
to the Venezuelans
urging them to do the same.
-Hola.
I'm Mike Pence, the Vice
President of the United States.
The United States supports
the courageous decision
by Juan Guaidó, the president
of your National Assembly,
to assert that body's
constitutional powers,
declare Maduro a usurper,
and call for the establishment
of a transitional government.
We say to all the good people
of Venezuela,
estamos con ustedes.
We are with you.
Muchas gracias.
Y vayan con Dios.
-Wow.
Mike Pence's Spanish
makes Michael Bloomberg
sound like the mayor
of Barcelona.
[ Laughter ]
There's something very odd
about hearing Mike Pence
say the word "hola."
It's like when the gym teacher
has to cover Spanish class.
"Hola. Señor Perez
is out with strep.
The assignment is on el boardo."
And while Pence
was backing Guaidó,
Trump was apparently
floating the possibility
of military intervention
to Republicans
like South Carolina senator
Lindsey Graham.
And even Graham, one of the most
pro-war politicians in Congress,
told Trump that was a bad idea.
-Senator Lindsey Graham says
that recently
as a couple of weeks ago,
President Trump
discussed the possibility
of using military force
in Venezuela.
Graham, recalling
his conversation with Trump,
told Axios, "Trump said,
'What do you think about
using military force?'
And I said, 'Well,
you need to go slow on that.
That could be problematic.'
And he said,
'Well, I'm surprised.
You want to invade everybody.'"
-Yeah, dude, seriously,
take a hint.
Even the guy who wants
to invade everybody
is telling you to relax.
It's like Kathie Lee and Hoda
telling you to cool it
on the Pinot.
Now, the scary thing about Trump
floating military action
in Venezuela
is that the people who used to
ignore his crazy fantasies,
like Mattis,
are no longer there.
Now Trump is surrounded
by hard-liners
like National Security Advisor
John Bolton,
who's called for regime change
in several countries,
and then there's Treasury
Secretary Steve Mnuchin.
On Monday, they held a briefing
at the White House
to unveil new sanctions
on Venezuela's oil sector.
-Today Treasury took action
against Venezuela's
state-owned oil company PDVSA.
Persons operating
in the Venezuelan oil sector
may now be subject to sanctions.
Refineries in the United States
have already been taking steps
to reduce the reliance
on imports from Venezuela.
Those imports have fallen
substantially in recent months.
-I'm sorry, but what is going on
with this map?
It's not exactly a good look
for this White House
when the map has all of Russia
and only half
of the United States.
Was this Trump's idea?
"This is the official map now.
California is gone."
[ Laughter ]
Now, there's concern
among experts
and some Democrats in Congress
that the sanctions could only
make the economic situation
in Venezuela worse
for the ordinary citizens.
But that wasn't the scariest
thing about the briefing.
The scariest thing
was what they didn't say --
specifically, what Bolton had
on his notepad
that was caught by the cameras.
-"The Washington Post"
reports a notepad
held by National Security
Advisor John Bolton
appeared to disclose
a possible plan
to send 5,000 U.S. troops
to Colombia.
It comes amid rising tensions
between the U.S. and Venezuela.
Bolton held the notepad
facing outward
during a White House briefing
yesterday.
There were two items
scrawled on the pad --
"Afghanistan, welcome the talks"
and "5,000 troops to Colombia."
-That's right.
Bolton was holding his notepad
toward the cameras,
and when they zoomed in, it said
"5,000 troops to Colombia."
Here's my question.
Why is he carrying around
a notepad
with only two sentences on it?
Just remember it.
When I go to the bathroom,
I don't need to write down
"brush teeth and floss."
The bottom line is this.
You can think Maduro is awful
and oppose him
and also think military action
is a bad idea.
Those aren't mutually exclusive.
We probably shouldn't
trust the same guys
who supported a disastrous war
in Iraq
to do a better job in Venezuela.
Instead of threatening war,
maybe call up allies
and countries in the region
and say...
-Hola.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]